and now the last one we have is you line
up bitcoin and eth mean transfer volume
per one dollar in fees uh what is this
showing us
yeah so this is kind of what i was
referring to a little bit earlier um you
know there's a lot of especially on
crypto twitter or people that are coming
into the space um they like to pit
bitcoin and eat against each other and i
think i think it's really just missing
the point in that they're two entirely
separate things um by far bitcoin is a
global monetary asset it's a political
it's a non-sovereign digital barrier
asset that no one can manipulate that no
one can change um it's meant to do two
things ex extremely well better than
anything before and that's store and
transfer value
across the internet in a digital native
way um where ethereum or you know other
crypto currencies as they're called are
you know smart contract platforms or you
can build daps or d5 protocols and all
these sorts of other things um
it's not competing with bitcoin and i
think the framing in general by most
people especially in the crypto space
you log on to coinbase one and two
bitcoin and each and people say what's
better what should i own um you know is
ether gonna flip in bitcoin without
really understanding that the the two
markets that they're competing for are
completely different
and you know despite maybe them
competing for inflows because people
download the coinbase app they're really
just not competing so what this is
showing is
essentially that you know i just in the
previous chart we showed uh bitcoin's
transfer volume per one dollars in fees
and basically that settlement efficiency
staying constant for the last decade
with some volatility and this chart is
showing bitcoin versus eth in that
regard and so as ethereum scales as
blockchains in general scale um with
ethereum doing nfts d5 dapps icos
whatever the next thing that ethereum or
these smart contract platforms can do um
it's in in terms of it as a settlement
network
a value settlement network it's it's far
inferior compared to bitcoin so for
every for every uh one dollar fee is
ethereum the base layer transfers 212
dollars of value with bitcoin at 67 000
of value and so
i just think the framing is wrong in
general i get a lot of questions i get a
lot of dms every day what do you think
about ethereum what do you think about
solana what do you think about
xyz uh and i think just in general the
total adjustable market for for
apolitical non-sovereign money uh in in
the digital age is a few hundred
trillion dollars and
uh the value of a smart contract
platform uh or you know whether it's
centralized decentralized or somewhere
in between and you can have that debate
all day
i think it's
it's just different and i think it's a
lot less but that's just a personal
opinion so i think in general the
framing is wrong and i think this kind
of data is pretty interesting to look at
okay so i got a couple more questions
then we're gonna take some questions
from the audience and my brothers as
well uh first one is 90 of bitcoin has
now been mined we talked about it
earlier on the show uh what's your
thought process there is that an
important milestone or you know it was
89.9 percent a couple days ago now it's
90. it's a round number it sounds nice
but doesn't really change anything
yeah i mean i think it's just pretty
remarkable when you think about
especially just in 2021 all of the the
you know announcements and all of the
news of new kind of capital flooding
into the bitcoin mining space i don't
know how many there are i think 20
publicly traded miners in the united
states um and you just you see just
these these companies raising massive
amounts of capital to invest to mine the
last 10 of the bitcoin supply over the
next hundred years and then that supply
issuance is um the the curve is you know
front loaded so you're gonna see five
percent of that or around five percent
of that bitcoin mind in the next uh
about four years or so um and so by 2030
i think it's around 99 or very close to
it
but just in terms of how much capital
how much resources and how much energy
is going to be dedicated to mining this
last 10 of bitcoin issued
it's pretty remarkable and it makes me
uh it makes me fumble and buy some more
bitcoin all right the other thing is um
that we just saw uh while we've been
talking lemonade which is a publicly
traded tech enabled insurance company uh
they've added bitcoin to their balance
sheet uh it's a very small amount it's
around a million dollars or so uh how do
you think about public companies adding
bitcoin to their balance sheet we've
seen michael saylor continue to buy
aggressively is this just a continuation
of the trend or do you feel like there's
been [ __ ] some shift in sentiment among
uh public executives
yeah i mean i think there's still um you
know michael saylor is far ahead of the
curve and i think if you're if you're
watching this and and are actively
stacking bitcoin you are
ahead of the curve as well um you know
these these companies and these
corporations these institutions they
move really slow have a lot some you
know michael saylor has 75 percent of
the voting rates at microstrategy he can
do what he wants
a lot of these companies you know like
twitter doesn't even have bitcoin in the
balance sheet and jack was a ceo so what
does you know kind of what does that say
in terms of uh other kind of competing
interests and just the information
asymmetry and so i think you know that
trend is going to continue and it's
going to uh pick up but just in terms of
allocating to bitcoin from a corporate
level the accounting standards still are
kind of unfavorable where if bitcoin
drops down it's a it's a loss on your
earnings some of these things they will
change in the future but
i think the trend where you see pensions
you see
corporate treasures you see insurance
funds just you know just a small
allocation to begin with um they're
allocating for years decades into the
future um and i think that's that's just
something we're going to see continue
but it'll take some time